das Hauptproblem beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
die
sagen wir mal die Auffassung von
Journalismus die nicht meine ist das ist
ja wirklich ein aktiv so wie heißt das
heute Aktivieren der Journalismus also
ich muss eine Haltung haben ich muss
nicht erst mal informieren und sagen was
ist sondern ich muss eigentlich sagen
was ich gerne hätte dass es ist und das
geht gar nicht beide Sender haben das
Problem dass sie um es mal sehr deutlich
zu sagen ziemlich grün versifft sind
selbst in Moderationen kommt das schon
vor selbst Tagesthemen Moderatoren
merkst du schon wohin Sie wollen statt
dass sie einfach ein Problem anreißen